United States Supreme Court
dealing Trump a major blow today, siding
with a House committee
seeking his tax returns.
CNN's senior Supreme Court analyst
Joan Biskupic has more information
for us.
So, Joan, what does this ruling mean?
This has been going on
for more than three years, Wolf.
The House Ways and Means
Committee has been trying to obtain
Donald former
President Trump's
tax returns as part of it.
Look at whether the IRS audits
of presidential records, how it works
should it be revised?
And the committee had argued
that it has a legitimate legislative
purpose on this.
And Trump had countered it, saying
this is just a witch hunt.
It's just an effort to embarrass him.
He had lost in lower courts
and the former president
had made a last ditch effort to the U.S.
Supreme Court.
And today, in a very brief two sentence
denial said,
no, we're not going to intervene.
The lower court decision stand.
And what this means
now is that the House Ways
and Means Committee
currently run by Democrats
currently for a short period.
Exactly.
Should be able to obtain from the IRS
the former president's tax returns.
And the committee chairman said today
that they were going to move forward
and try to continue their exploration
of exactly
what's in his tax returns
and whether the IRS audit
program needs any kind of revision.
And it looked like
it was pretty unanimous.
The Supreme Court.
Well, that's an excellent question
because on paper, on what we got
from the Supreme Court,
there were no recorded dissents.
But, Wolf, my experiences
that sometimes there might be dissents
behind the scenes
and they just don't
want to go public with it.
But if they didn't go public with it,
all we've got is a flat out
rejection of the former president,
even the Supreme Court justices
appointed by Trump. Exactly right.
At least we're silent on this, right?
That's exactly right.
John, thank you very, very much.
Let's get some more analysis right now.
Joining us,
defense attorney
Jan Wu and the state attorney
for Palm Beach County
in Florida, Dave Aronberg.
Paula Reed is still back with us as well.
Shannon,
let me begin with this face off
between the Justice Department
and the former president's legal team.
Based on what we heard today.
Do you expect
federal prosecutors
will be successful
in getting rid
of the so-called special master,
reviewing the documents
recovered from Mar a Lago?
Judging from what
we've heard
and as Paul was referencing
the questions from the panel,
it seems like that is a possibility.
I mean, I would applaud that decision.
I think it is very dangerous
for the precedent of letting
criminal defendants
interpose a civil type of mechanism
to basically slow down
the criminal prosecution.
So I think that may happen
given the direction that the courts.
The Court of appeals questions
seem to be going in Wolf.
Well, Paula,
how significant would a Justice
Department victory
be for the special counsel?
The new special counsel, Jack Smith,
Incredibly significant,
Wolf, because that would allow them
to move forward with this investigation
more more swiftly.
And really, time is of the essence.
You heard the attorney general on Friday
when he announced
the appointment of Jack Smith,
the special counsel.
He was assuring people
that this appointment
would not slow this down.
There are concerns about how long
these investigations
are going to drag out,
especially given the 2024
presidential election cycle.
So if they can remove
this review process,
that would allow them
to move more quickly
Now, I've also talked to someone
Jack Smith used to work
for the Justice Department.
He said, look,
this is not a guy that Donald
who doesn't sit on things.
He does move swiftly.
And this
this would really be a win for him.
Dave Aronberg,
let's turn to this decision
from the United States Supreme Court
today to allow
the House of Representatives,
this committee in the House
to review former President Trump's
tax returns.
Trump's legal team
has continuously fought
to keep his tax returns secret.
Just how significant of a loss is this
for the former president?
Wolf, it's a
big loss because
the Trump legal strategy
has always been delay, delay, delay.
I think they knew
they were going to lose,
but they wanted to
to draw it out long enough
until the Republicans
could get control of Congress
while they're six weeks short.
The Democrats are now going to be able
to get these tax returns
and possibly
hand them over to DOJ
if there are
some criminal evidence there.
You know,
the federal law is pretty clear here.
The Ways and Means Committee
has the authority to see any taxpayer's
documents
and Congress
has broad lawmaking
and oversight authority.
So this was always going to go
the government's way.
It was just a question of when.
And, you know, in the end,
this is only an issue
because Trump is the first president
in modern
history, history
to refuse to turn over his taxes
to the American public.
He promised to do so.
He never did so, Wolf.
Somewhere in Tallahassee,
Rhonda Santos is smiling.
Good point.
You know, Shannon,
what information
can this House committee glean
from these tax documents and what impact
might this have on the former
president's various
outstanding legal fights?
I think they can glean a lot from it.
Less clear
exactly what we as the public
will get to see from it.
But I think one issue is that
he's bragged
about the tax avoidance strategies,
and that may be very damning evidence
of his.
What's revealed
corroborates the idea
that he's exaggerated
his inflated things.
As we're taking a look in New York State
right now
at whether
there was tax
avoidance strategies being used
by the company.
So it's very valuable evidence.
That's why
people generally
don't like
to have their tax returns
revealed,
because there's
a lot of valuable evidence
that can be mined from that.
I mean, with Trump, I mean, the
the seeking of his tax
returns has been like the Holy Grail
in Trumpworld.
I mean, he's fought so hard against it.
And I think one interesting point
to Dave's point,
too, is by fighting
so hard on every single issue,
it creates the illusion
sometimes that a setback
is a great victory.
This is just Congress
doing what it's supposed to do.
And he managed
to drag out for such a long time.
Where it goes from here
really does remain to be seen.
We'll find out fairly soon.
Paula, as you know, Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham
today completed his appearance
before the Georgia
special grand jury investigating efforts
to overturn the 2020
presidential election.
How great a threat does this case pose
to Trump? Himself?
Well, I've asked the
former president's attorneys
that exact question, Wolf,
and they've told me that they believe
that the investigation in Fulton County
looking into
whether the former
president and his associates
tried to interfere in the 2020
presidential election,
that is highly likely
that he could
potentially be charged there.
They think of all the investigations
that is the one
that arguably their immediate
in the immediate future
the most concerned about.
Now they would also tell you that
they don't think
the case
will ultimately stick
and there wouldn't be a conviction
if charges are actually brought.
But the senator is
just the most recent
in a line of high profile witnesses,
including the governor of Georgia,
White House aides who have appeared
just in the past few weeks.
So that investigation is active, ongoing
and even his own attorneys say,
yes, they're concerned about
what's going on in Fulton County.
Very significant legal
developments unfolding today.
Guys, thank you very, very much.